our own clay travis tweeted quote while
amber heard was hit with the 15 million
dollar verdict for defamation remember
the five million punitive damages was
really reduced by the judge according to
the commonwealth law of virginia to 350
thousand
we shouldn't overlook he said the
washington post
published her defamatory lies after
editing and posting a headline to the
piece a jury is now officially
determined they publish fake news here
with reaction fox news contributor joe
concha along with outkick founder clay
travis clay i thought your angle was
dead on accurate
but we all know if you're a public
figure that again we go to times v
sullivan you need to prove actual malice
uh is there a case here that you might
see that they would have against the
washington post meaning johnny depp
yeah it's fascinating uh sean and thanks
for having me on that's what justice
clarence thomas has argued that we need
to update times v sullivan for the
modern era and so when i put my lawyer
hat on here and go back to when i
practice law full time what jumps out to
me sean is yes there probably is a claim
against the washington post now this was
an op-ed piece right so she's claiming
to tell the truth to what extent was
there an investigation done remember
they definitely wrote the headline which
was a major consequential aspect of this
case what it really represents though
big picture here is the washington post
has sold the hashtag believe all women
they have sold me too sean you know what
they did to brett kavanaugh and the
awful lies that they spread as a part of
news coverage during his confirmation
hearings what this represents and i
think it's a massive significant win for
the american legal system is we are back
now to square one lady justice is blind
for a reason when she's holding up the
scales of justice it's because whether
you're a man or woman whether you're
black white asian hispanic gay straight
a citizen of this country or not we are
all supposed to be equal before the eyes
of justice and in fact our stories are
to be given weight not based on our
identity but based on their truth and
what this jury said was even though the
washington post tried to defame johnny
depp and even though all of hollywood
and all of the media jumped on the amber
herd bandwagon and believed this he
still deserved his day in court and that
jury said we're not hashtag believing
all women this is the end of hashtag me
too this is about individuals being able
to tell their own story johnny depp
struck a blow i really believe this for
the justice system helping to tear down
this awful idea that if you're a woman
you can't lie we all know men i believe
humans lie
but but but clay you got to get to this
point i believe
when but i also believe that you're
innocent until proven guilty the
presumption of innocence and nobody at
the time when this was at its height
wanted to talk about that aspect of this
joe control more broadly when we talk
about the when we talk about the media
joe i was in atlanta when the whole
olympic bombing happened i was on the
air
there when richard jewell fit the
profile of the lone bomber turned out he
was a hero there and it taught me a very
valuable lesson that has served me well
throughout my career
we were right about nicholas sandman we
were right about ferguson we were right
about cambridge we were right about uva
we were right about duke lacrosse we
were right about baltimore maryland the
russia hoax for three years we're now
proven right and we were even right on
the hunter biden laptop story these are
not insignificant moments in the case of
the russia hoax
those lies went on for three long years
and dragged the country through hell and
none of the allegations in that dirty
dossier were true none of the alpha bank
allegations were true
and all those stories you just mentioned
had a common thread a common mantra sean
and that is you're guilty until proven
innocent not the other way around
whether you want to bring up richard
jewell or nicholas sandman and i think
sandman here probably is the most
relevant person to think about if johnny
depp's next move in court is to go after
the washington post because you remember
the post along with cnn they were sued
for defamation by a high school student
to the tune of 275 million dollars each
and both of those publications were
forced to settle so will the post be
facing a similar suit here from johnny
depp i mean stay tuned sean but either
way in the end i'm going to be hearing
those three words over and over again uh
from the testimony from this case has
gone on for weeks sean and i got to be
honest it's hard to get out of my head
human fecal matter i mean that's a tough
one to erase from that bed never have i
realized how normal my marriage was
until now so i guess we could all
appreciate who we have in our lives
after seeing these two go at it well
i i will tell you it in so many on so
many different levels and i know you're
being funny but it is so dark it is so
ugly there's no light
there is
for things to deteriorate and go this
low
neither one of these two come out
looking good money no money win no win
here i i think it's everybody loses
across the board the only thing i can
say is to other people if you find
yourself in such a situation as nancy
grace rightly pointed out get the hell
out of it immediately don't pass go
don't collect 200 get out leave
sad tragic in so many ways thank you
both for being with us hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else